there's three types of income most
people are working hard for earned
income
the trouble with earned income in
America at tax rates approximately fifty
percent or as warren buffett says is
ashamed that his secretary pays a higher
percentage in taxes and he did although
he makes billions but what you say to a
child go to school and get a safe secure
job you telling the work for earned
income the worst type of income the
second type of income is portfolio
income and today as I speak and they're
trying to change this it's about 20
percent in portfolio income is generally
known as capital gains if I buy a stock
for ten dollars and I sell it for $50
the $40 tax it at 20% or if I buy a
house for a hundred thousand I sell it
for two hundred thousand that's a
capital gains type event so you pay a
lot of tax for that and the third type
of income which is the best type of
income is passive income this is income
that just comes in on a regular basis
one of the reasons I am wealthy and is
able to retire at a young age is because
I worked hard for passive income not
earned income I don't flip real estate
generally not portfolio income I don't
flip stocks I want passive income and if
you know what you're doing you can pay
zero pratense
percent taxes legally and this can be
done all over the world most successful
entrepreneurs have gone bust Henry Ford
an old-time entrepreneur he went bust
look at Steve Jobs his own board fired
him Bill Gates was taken before the
Supreme Court for monopolistic practices
even my friend Donald Trump went down a
billion dollar I only went down a
million so the average person is so
afraid of those losses they never get
ahead because at school they teach you
if you make a mistake or if you fail
you're a failure that's not real life a
baby alarms to walk by standing up and
falling down standing up and falling
down and our school system punishes you
for making mistakes that's why my poor
debt an academic was so unsuccessful he
was terrified of making
you just watched two amazing clips from
Robert Kiyosaki take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]